They say when a YouTuber is dying, the videos
flash before their eyes.
Like the psychological horrors of Live Alone.
Or the haunting isolation of Microhorror:
The End.
Remember that time I interviewed Marina Joyce?
"Marina?
Marina!
What's happening?
Marina!"
Everybody loved Al Dente Creepypasta.
"...holograms looked shockingly realistic."
And True Fear.
"Last time on True Fear..."
I want to talk about more trailers with you.
"...Pennywise's reflection right here, you'll
notice that IT's eyes don't seem to reflect
in the water."
I want to do more :15 second horrors.
More Deadstreams.
I'M NOT SATISFIED WITH STOPPING NOW.
So many ideas.
I must find a way to create more.
Assuming we both survive.